we're back with one of my favorite
people james gordon
by the way you're incredibly humble and
i so appreciate that because you were
so well known in england and i'm just so
glad that you
knew who you were and what you wanted to
do because having that strong
point of view was the catapult that just
made it work right out of the gate
i think for me you know having children
being a father making this move to
america was it was a really
it was it was a a daunting yet
incredibly exciting thing to do that as
a
as a family and like my wife and i we
we've always seen it as
this will be just this little american
adventure
and so all you want to feel when you
look back at something
retrospectively is not just proud of the
show that you're making but proud of the
relationships that you
made and the friendships that you formed
and i'm just very very lucky
that i go to work every day with some
people who are incredibly talented
who guide me in the best way to
to make this show and you said something
that i think is
sort of should be put a knit on a pillow
or you know laminated and like put
out there for people to read you said
i want to take this opportunity that i
have and
consider it a blank page every single
day i'll tell you what i do every
day which i think i learned from doing
like long runs of plays and things in
whether that be in like london or in new
york is
some days when you're doing a play and
you're on show
385 and you're walking down the stairs
on a wednesday afternoon to do a matinee
you can really sometimes be like oh man
i don't know how i'm going to do this
but then
i think to myself imagine when you
finish
someone taps you on the shoulder and
goes oh by the way that's it
that's the last time you're going to do
that you're not going to do that now
that's done so um best of luck pack up
your stuff and go
and you sort of go well if this was my
last show
and none of us know when it will be if
it was my last show how would i want it
to be and how would i want to remember
it and then i go well i really like to
just have a great time
i would like to have a really really
really great time doing it
and that's kind of that's the thing i
feel like the job
is two jobs what you do and what i do
it's two jobs right now there's the job
of like the day
where you're producing things
brainstorming things could this work
could we do that how would we do that is
that possible i don't know
and then as soon as the show starts you
go my only job now for the next hour is
to have a blast
and if i have a blast then that's the
that's
that's my day's work and that's a pretty
good day's work
any day you can you know what's
happening are you getting undressed um
i've done it before and that's not how i
think you should do your last day
you think it's your last show i will do
it naked i don't think that's a good
idea
um i wrote this on my arm i don't know
if anyone can see it
yeah and uh tattoo shops are closed
right now
so i'm waiting and i wrote it with a
tattoo pen and i've been writing it
on my arm every single day since the day
before
uh we launched because you push so hard
in that creation you look at that blank
page with
excitement and fear and enthusiasm
and a dizzying amount of possibility and
somewhere along the way i realized am i
enjoying this because if i'm not that
energy is not going to be
the right thing that as you said when
you sit down sort of funnels out and
that's the whole intention
um and i i think
the rest i'm i'm here to figure out
because i'm a student
yeah but everyone is like
you that's the important thing to
remember is
edu education doesn't stop you are on a
lifelong
quest of education and you're and
and if you're constantly seeking that if
you're open
to opportunities opportunities in front
of you and also open to the very notion
that there is a chance
that you might be wrong then your life
will be a
a quest of education yeah that's uh look
at us this is like a therapy session
i know i love it so much and i love the
mantra also make it personal
because our own little weird odd
authenticity is all we have and i just
love what you do
james i love your spirit and your
journey and i'm
cheering you on and i'm so thrilled to
be talking with you here today
uh in this studio and i was wondering if
i could try to give you a hug please
because i just i know
that it's breaking the rules but i don't
know if we're allowed to do that i don't
know if we're allowed
to try even even uh if there's a little
bit of distance
kept between us there might be a way how
do i do this
we could stick our tushies out and
um there you go look hang on open that
wait there you go
there oh that's a great hug would it be
okay if i just got inside of you
sure there you are look at that step
forward
no what is wrong with me i had it
darn it i love doing the ghost can i can
i throw you a pillow
sure can you throw me a pillow i'll
throw you a pillow you ready hang on
okay from los angeles to new york one
two three
do you have an apple i'm very hungry
oddly oddly i do that wait what are the
chances
is that an apple i'm never without an
apple that is do you want this apple
yes i do i'm very hungry okay
one two three go
james i can't thank you enough i
i remember when we were getting to shoot
on cbs
at the lot together we had so much fun
i will always be grateful to be in your
orbit if only for a moment you are so
lovely
i love being in your orbit james i
celebrate you
[Music]